naja fertig sein
nachtisch das bin ich ich habe gerade
was abgefahrenes erfahren was genau
erzähle ich euch gleich aber was ist
hier eigentlich in meinem gesicht los
das ist eine so genannte beim office
expression und ist wissenschaftlich
höchst interessant menschen sind
emotionale wesen und das sehr
offensichtlich dass wir unsere gefühle
mimisch und körpersprachlich ausdrücken
beweist dass der homo sapiens ein hoch
soziales wesen ist soziale interaktionen
sind wichtig wenn nicht sogar
überlebenswichtig vielleicht kennt noch
jemand dieses video wo ich erkläre warum
wir weinen und warum wir rot werden es
ist wichtig dass wir unsere gefühle in
non verbal kommunizieren können andere
können zum beispiel leicht erkennen wenn
wir uns sehr freuen
aber manchmal drücken wir freude auch so
aus dieses phänomen ist in der
psychologie als beim office expression
also zwei gestaltete emotionen bekannt
davon spricht man wenn sich das erlebte
gefühl und der gefühlsausdruck
widersprechen manche weinen obwohl sie
glücklich sind andere zeigen aggressives
verhalten nehmen wir meinen mann
matthias matthias ist dortmund-fan wird
dortmund verliert dann sieht das so aus
wenn dortmund gewinnt dann sieht das so
aus
ohne ton und kontext kaum zu
unterscheiden spielerische aggressionen
sind übrigens als kita crashen speed
verbreitet er kennt das nicht ihr seht
ein süßes baby oder eine flasche das
tier und ihr denkt euch nicht kennt sc
cajun manchmal machen wir aber auch und
wollen uns gar nicht zum lachen zumute
ist zum beispiel aus verzweiflung die
mosel gefühls ausdrücke sind also
überall aber wissenschaftlich werden sie
erst seit einigen jahren untersucht
sowie aber warum stehst du jetzt
psychologen mit kittel und schutzbrille
da es ist schon so ein bisschen
diskriminieren nicht alle
wissenschaftler sind chemiker freut mich
weil ich bin jetzt realistisch
dargestellt oder was sie psychologie
arianna errigo und fand heraus dass
menschen die leicht in freudentränen aus
brechen auch eher das bedürfnis haben
süße tiere zu quetschen sie glaubt dass
die moore für gefühle den zweck haben
sehr starke emotionen zu kompensieren
denn auch stark positive emotionen
setzen uns außer gefecht und damit das
nicht eskaliert hilft eine gegenteilige
reaktion wie tränen oder aggressionen
dabei uns schneller zu erholen es gibt
noch zwei weitere theorien die bisher
untersucht sind theorie nummer eins in
wirklichkeit fühlte betroffene
tatsächlich zwei widersprüchliche
emotionen gleichzeitig und hinter
freudentränen steckt auch ein kleines
bisschen trauer mir doch nur
unterbewusst sprich menschen weinen bei
hochzeiten weil sie eigentlich auch
traurig sind also ich war auf keinen
fall traurig
das glaubst du vielleicht moment das
muss jetzt erst mal wissenschaftlich
nachgewiesen theorie nummer zwei unser
gehirn kann manchmal nicht zwischen
freude und trauer unterscheiden wenn die
emotionen sehr stark sind es wäre doch
mal interessant solche den morden
gefühls ausdrücke unter einem
hirnscanner zu beobachten die frage ist
nur wie stellt man solche extremen
gefühle reproduzierbar in einem labor
setting her
was denkt ihr welchen zweck haben die
moore für gefühle und wie könnte eine
wissenschaftliche reproduzierbare
methode aussehen um sie im labor zu
untersuchen jeder gute methoden
vorschlag kriegt von mir persönlich ein
keks e-motor und in der endart erzählt
euch mai noch was sie am anfang des
videos krasses erfahren hat freunde der
sonne
mai lab wurde für den grimme online
award nominiert ist so unfassbar
verrückt dass ich es auch nicht anders
handeln kann als miley jetzt ernsthafte
chancen hat für den preis
das will ich mir gar nicht vorstellen
erhöhte gefahr für die moore für freund
reden denn allein die nominierung ehrt
mich so sehr aber ihr könnt für weile
abstimmen denn neben den jury preise
gibt es auch einen publikumspreis das
heißt falls ihr freunde der sonne seit
er schaut in die video beschreibung
dasteht wie ihr mir helfen können
nächsten donnerstag habe ich dann wieder
ein längeres video für euch mit ganz
viel seien
wir sehen uns bis dahin bleibt sicher